"Okay, let's do the usual Computerphile: Mac or PC?"
Mac, of course.
I use a PC.
I use a Mac quite a lot of the time. I do have- I possess some PCs.
Oh, it's got to be PC. Definitely.
For Derek McAuley, who's also known as Mac, it's Mac.
Not a PC.
"Mac for Mac."
Mac for Mac.
Ugh, PC.
"Mac or PC?"
Mac.
Um, Linux.
*cough* *chucle*
Mac.
"Mac or PC?"
PC. Linux.
I've gone very Mac, as you can see.
I probably prefer a Mac, but I've got a PC.
Uh, Mac.
Um, I use Windows.
Whichever's appropriate.
I do Mac now.
PC.
"Mac or PC?"
Oh, Chromebook. Neither. Linux man.
At the moment, it is still, for me, PC plus Linux.
But at some vague stage in the near future, I may capitulate and go for a fully Mac solution.
In the course of doing these videos for you, I've seen people catch sight of an Apple on what they think
is my desk. Well, I have to say, sadly, it's not mine. It belongs to my colleague because we share this room
and he's not in very often. But when he is, he uses the Apple Macintosh.
And yet- Well, I've also confused you totally by referring to the fact that I run openSUSE
and I also have a straightforward Windows 7 PC.
I use Windows, which is a fairly controversial decision amongst my friends.
But there is not a Mac laptop that actually does what I want it to.
There's not a Mac laptop with a significant enough graphics card that will work
and no decent video editing software on Linux. so...
I've been preaching for years that one should be using the same machine
and the people actually produce the machine, they also produce the software so they are compatible.
And meanwhile, was using Windows on a Dell.
And one day I decided, it was enough of crashes and my blackbay not communicating with Dell.
So I said, "That's it." I moved to Mac and all done.
PC
"Okay, how's that then?"
Hehehe, *inaudible*
Apart from Steven, Steven's a real Mac fan.
Mac, most of the time, at the moment.
"Yeah, well, any reason for that?"
Um, at the time, good full factor- for the hardware
Um, pretty well made
Um, the software is no more exasperating than PC, so far, so
Having done, the Mac, and, um, more about
The Mac age 30 years and so on
I have to say, they're still not my first choice
They were back in the eighties but, let's try and
Offend everybody, or let's try and mollify everybody.
Had I been a graphic designer, and not a computer scientist
I would certainly have gone for a Mac
Because all of the things that matter to Graphic Designers
Worked really, really well
And they were designed, for the Mac, first of all, and it shows in everything they do.
I'm the only one in the office that uses the Apple
And, I get slicied? for it, so
They're all Windows guys around here
I've always used a PC and, um, Apple, are very expensive
Um, and they have a rather draconian warranty system
That, I'd like to avoid
Just, I'm kind of fond of Mac phone thing
It's historical, I've been, on a PC for, many, many millenium
I think the problem for real computer scientists
Was the Macintosh was good, but it was signle user, it was for Graphic Designers
It didn't participate in the world of networked Unix m achines
Um, linux, *cough* *chuckle*
"PC, PC not Mac?"
Um, well no, whatever architecture, any architecture
I like the ??? chromebook, I'm a massive Google fanboy
And um, other than that I like the- it's the nicest, linux PC you can get
I'm Mac these days.
"Ok, any particular reason?"
Yeah first I was linux, and then I found, too much hassle
Installing sound drivers, and whatever, and updating operating systems and moved to Mac
I have just always have used PCs
And, you know, I'm not against Macs, particularly, but um
Yeah PCs
I was a bit annoyed with Mac and those, erm
Copyright, *inaudible*
"Digital Theft", I call this
The Macintosh didn't participate in the world of networked Unix machines
Until relatively late on, and as many of you know that came about with Steve Jobs forming NeXT
NeXT was built on a Unix-like system, and so now that it's come full circle
Steve Jobs came back to Apple, brought this Unix-type system with him
Then all of a sudden, yes, now, I can live on a Mac, quite happily
And colleague Steve, is an absolute raving Mac enthusiast for just that reason
*chuckle*
Are there other computers?
It's totally Unix-based, you can have the best of both worlds
You can have the graphic richness, you can have a Unix-like environment as well